ethereum has this new uh
update right in terms of the monetary
policy and the burning mechanism etc
what is your understanding or kind of
read as to positive negative are you
neutral how do you think this affects
ethereum moving forward so i got
completely savage day one
on twitter when i talked about
eip1559 actually increasing fee levels
apparently that was uh something that
had been forecasted so
people didn't like that i pointed that
out um but uh
my was it right uh yeah yeah so like
fees on ethereum are like i would say
structurally higher now
and really what eip1559 did was cut out
the floor
in terms of fees so
when
you know you'd have periods on a theorem
of downtime where it would get pretty
cheap to transact
the new eip kind of just eliminated that
and set
like a higher threshold minimum
threshold to sort of transact i'm vastly
oversimplifying
but
generally my read is that um
it's sort of consistently like pretty
pricey to transact
of course you got you know the ethereum
community got this great thing in return
which is burning a significant share
of all the fees that you know would be
paid to miners miners are making as much
revenue now
as they were before and also
um i think a majority of those fees are
being burned
so think about what that means from a
user perspective
so that's good and bad on the one hand
you can make this argument hey if we
actually reduce the issuance the theorem
can become deflationary from a monetary
perspective it's a great story to tell
investors
um the negative thing and this is
something i try to communicate and i'm
trying to be fair and balanced here
is
um
it's a form of rent extraction right so
initially the miners all of the fees
were going to pay miners for their
service of keeping the block space
linear and you know doing the thing that
miners do
now a you know good portion of the fees
associated with using ethereum just go
to effectively
juicing the price of a theorem right by
you know potentially reducing the supply
and so that really benefits token
holders
at the expense of users of the
blockchain and now a lot of ethereums
will say to me like well token holders
are users so it's all the same thing but
if you expect a theorem to mature
and you have a lot of firms that hold a
theorem just for working capital
perspective just to utilize the
blockchain transact on it without
wanting to have financial exposure to
ether
those firms are going to feel
disempowered because you know the
ethereum governance process increased
the costs of using ethereum
and funneled that sort of return into
the token price and so now what you have
thanks to the cip is like these two
groups these stakeholder groups are at
odds with each other
you know people that are long-term uh
you know effectively speculators not to
use the pejoratively on the token price
and then people and i think this is the
most important demographic that you want
to sort of uh curry favor with you want
to sort of coddle them is the people
that use and hold ethereum as working
capital but that ladder group is a
little disempowered by the change in my
view so that's uh you know i'm certainly
not known to be like you know deeply
part of the ethereum community so i this
wasn't received very well when i said it
when you think about this because it's
an interesting um
framework that you're using where token
holders can see price go up which
people on twitter etc are like they love
that idea right so they're gonna applaud
you for for that thought process
but you're basically saying yes but the
people who are using this this may
actually be a negative impact and so is
it fair to say that your analysis is
this could be short-term good because
price goes up but actually long-term
sustainability over a 10-year period or
something could put
more stress or kind of be bigger
obstacles or more complexity moving
forward because of the change
yeah i think there could well be a
reckoning where it's people begin to
understand
that these somewhat opaque governance
processes
are not
being uh you know they're not
necessarily weighing the interest of all
stakeholders uh equally
and there could well be a moment where
people realize wow we turned up the rent
extraction dial too high
and we got to turn it back now i think
that's completely plausible i don't
think people are really ready to hear
that message maybe fees need to be
really high for a long time and these
other smart contract competitors start
to do really really well which we've
seen that's happened in the last week or
so just you know
appreciating relative to ethereum uh but
yeah i think there could be a reckoning
over the unanticipated impacts of
tweaking things that look like technical
things but they're actually political
changes so my view of this has been and
i want to see if you want to agree or
disagree and then two also like how you
think this will play moving forward is
uh there was bitcoin people try to do
things with it they were unhappy with
the technical kind of architecture and
how easy it would be they went and they
built ethereum uh for the all intents
and purposes they were able to
accomplish the composability that they
were looking for that led to d5 many of
these other things
but then they started to hit kind of a
limiting wall and so flow you know is
one example but you've also had the
binary smart chains of the world you've
got things like solana et cetera that
are now starting to pop up and it almost
feels like to some degree uh there's a
lot more technical competition among the
smart contract platforms let's say
bitcoin and something else that's
competing from a monetary standpoint
and so
if that is true and you can agree or
disagree with it is this something where
the old like what is myspace what is
facebook what is the next social network
whatever
that is more likely to play out along
the
smart contract technical competition
like landscape not claiming any one of
them is any one of those companies you
know equivalent but just saying like
there is going to be ones that find
success there's going to be ones that
disrupt there's always going to be new
challengers and like you're going to
constantly have to iterate and innovate
your way to stay at the front of the
pack to hold both the one the economic
holders but also to the users of the
platform because it seems like bitcoin
is it either works or it doesn't but no
one's really competing for that like
decentralized programmatic you know
monetary policy etc and so it's kind of
a one or zero here it doesn't feel that
way when you talk about the smart
contract platforms yeah i mean i i don't
remotely think of these things in terms
of the analogies to uh social networks
um i you know
if you think about the key decisions
that are made whether it's changes
bitcoin i mean the block size change
as i said with eip1559 these look like
technical changes but really they are
pertaining governance and they pretend
to you know who are the winners and
losers in the system who are the
entities that can extract rent from
being proximate to the protocol and who
are the entities that are being
effectively harvested by the protocol
elites not to you know kind of
engage in fear-mongering or anything but
that is at the core of any real major
change that happens in any blockchain is
um who are we empowering by virtue of
our changes to the protocol and who are
we disempowering
and oftentimes developers don't
acknowledge that they're engaged in
politics they think they're engaged in
engineering but it's politics because
there's billions of dollars on the line
how much are they influenced in your
opinion by
the non-engineering community so whether
it's people on twitter whether it's
large asset managers whether it's folks
like they've taken the ethereum system
consensus if you look at solana
ftx and that crowd like
how much of it's coming from
the people who aren't actually writing
the code versus do you think these are
are technical decisions that are being
made
by the engineers and they just have
ramifications in the political uh
analysis well it's hard to quantify i
mean it depends on the blockchain but
you have this tyranny of
structurelessness right where
in a non-formalized system which is the
governance of most blockchains it's not
formalized
power still exists it's just veiled it's
opaque so it's not clear who has power
and then in in a highly technocratic
system
it's a lot of engineers that uh you know
take up this role as you know
policymakers people that can actually
influence the governance of the system i
would say that's what i mostly perceive
is these like backdoor um you know
pretty opaque like pretty hard to
understand as a regular person
uh you know settings where decisions are
made
and uh you know it's largely technocrats
okay you know effectively very technical
uh engineers that are making political
decisions um of course you do
occasionally have you know influence uh
and and it's getting more blurred now as
you have more interest groups and you
know more large corporates that try and
inject themselves into you know these
governance conversations uh like you
know new york agreement things like that
uh and you also have more sponsorship
accord devs which muddies the waters but
i'd say you know like historically it's
largely technocratic and also hard for
an outsider to sort of get a handle on
what's up guys bang bang your boy pomp
thanks so much for watching the best
business show our goal is to make this
the largest most actionable business
show in the world and to do that we need
your help we've partnered with sofi as
our exclusive sponsor because they have
a piece of software that we think will
help you take the information that we
share on a daily basis and make it
actionable we want every single person
to pursue and achieve financial security
and financial freedom in order to do
that you gotta act and sofi allows you
to do it so you can go to sofi.com
today you can open up an account and
when you open up an account you can
invest in all sorts of different types
of assets etfs individual stocks ipos
bitcoin cryptocurrencies they even have
an automated investing function if you
want to invest sofi can help you they've
got a couple of different offers that
you can benefit from the first open an
invest account and they'll give you up
to a thousand bucks for free kind of a
no-brainer second is if you go on and
you buy one of the cryptocurrencies that
they offer they'll go ahead and they'll
give you ten dollars of bitcoin for free
and third some of you are saying i
already have a brokerage account i
already have an account somewhere else
right now you can get up to five
thousand dollars for transferring your
account that's right sofi doesn't care
where your current account is but if you
transfer it from that place to sofi
they'll pay you up to five thousand
dollars for doing it why wouldn't you do
it it's up to five thousand dollars for
free head on over to sofi.com today to
get started and come back tomorrow and
watch more the best business show
together we're to build the biggest show
in the world
[Music]